is the free democratic party's candidate
for the german bundestag
representing schleswig-holstein
campaigning means shaking hands
learning about the land and the people
drawing attention to oneself
and lots and lots of traveling
first of all buchholz is just a normal
person who used to be in another line of
work
he's got a few political ideas and he'd
like to put them into practice in berlin
such as
a few economic policy ideas where i've
got some clear positions
i used to be the domestic and
legislative policy spokesman for our
state parliamentary group
and it's no secret that i stand for
traditional liberal positions on
individual freedom
and protection of privacy and personal
data is
election district is the baltic sea
island of feyman
like most of eastern holstein it's all
about tourism
and agriculture most of the people along
the coast
live from tourism
the candidate's first appearance of the
day is at a holiday resort with
accommodations for 2 800 people
the hotel manager valtrod cup employs a
staff of 150
and she's planning to invest some 20
million euros
in renovating the facilities
as a tourism entrepreneur what do you
expect from a possible
fdp bundestag representative
i expect him to oppose any tax increases
and i want to see support continue for
those of us in tourism
as a former publishing business
executive he's especially interested in
issues like these
this really broadens my horizons to deal
with completely different things
as i always told my reporters be curious
and inquisitive now i can do that myself
schleswig-holstein's state capital is
the baltic sea port of
kiel this is where bucholtz launched his
political career
he served as an opposition fdp
representative in the state parliament
from 1992 to 1996
before moving to the private sector
until a year ago bucholtz was board
chairman of gruner and yar in hamburg
europe's largest publishing house now a
millionaire
he hopes to return to politics
i didn't inherit anything i worked for
it and i worked hard
i'm not ashamed of the money i earned
and besides it makes me independent
personally and economically
just what people want
he moves on from the boardroom straight
to folk foss hagen's pig style
the farmer farmer's proud of his model
operation with its 1300 sows
but the piglets aren't ready to hear the
candidate's political message
many voters react much the same way
the next day bernd bucholtz is in bad
zegeberg
he spends weekends on the campaign trail
family and hobbies
such as golf sailing and motorcycling
will have to wait
it's tiring and not always fun he's only
been a candidate for a few months so
many don't know pujols
who have we been talking to the one on
the cover here
i'm not a politician yet but i want to
be yes
he could get elected at least i think
he's the type regular folks would vote
for
no mindful thank you sean
is a rich man a millionaire i get the
impression all the free democrats are
millionaires
seen here at the fdp's last federal
party conference in may
wolfgang kubiki and bert buchholz are
the three democrats top candidates in
schleswig-holstein
if all goes according to plan they'll
both win seats in parliament
at the party conference the free
democrats finalized their election
platform
there were long debates about every
little detail and constant revisions
that surprised pujols
i wouldn't say the decision-making
process is much better in the business
world
from my point of view it's definitely
not but things progress in a timely
manner
by virtue of the hierarchy there's
someone who says
now we must cut the gordian knot and
this is what we'll do
it's different in politics here you have
to find a majority and convince people
this takes a bit longer and you must
accept that
back on the campaign trail bucholtz
takes part in a podium discussion about
old age poverty spurring with candidates
from other parties
he must present good arguments and
answer questions from voters and
political opponents
the free democrat is both eloquent and
confident
after events like that the
schleswig-holstein ftp summer party
provides a welcome change
here bucholtz is among friends and feels
at home
here people know him and he can make
valuable contacts even germany's top
diplomat showers praise on bent bucholtz
what impresses me is that he's already
held political offices
then he switched to the business world
and was successful there
and now he's returned to politics it's
precisely this kind of exchange between
practical professions and political
engagement
that's good for the bundestag
winning a seat in the bundestag that's
been
and he's confident he can make it come
true